je suis iris Berthomier j'ai 33 ans je
suis membre du Mouvement Démocrate je
suis élue ici dans le sixième
arrondissement de Paris et je suis en
charge des questions de handicap de
santé et d'alimentation durable
je suis conseillère d'arrondissement
donc ça veut dire que je fais partie du
conseil municipal à l'échelle de
largement j'ai été élu en 2020 en pleine
crise Ovide juste après le confinement
on a hébergé ici à l'intérieur de la
Mairie du 6e un centre de vaccination
c'est une réalisation dont je suis très
fière il y a évidemment d'autres
réalisations je pense par exemple on a
eu une exposition de peinture dans la
mairie de mettre en valeur les peintures
réalisées par des enfants en situation
de handicap qui sont scolarisés dans le
6ème arrondissement alors j'ai adhéré au
modem en 2014 j'étais encore étudiante
en droit et donc je ne sentais proche
des valeurs du Mouvement démocrate qui
prenait des valeurs de démocratie
d'attachement à l'Europe également la
défense de l'idée d'un courant central
en France qui n'existait pas à l'époque
de je croyais assez fort à cette idée
développée par François Bayrou et ça m'a
donné envie d'adhérer j'ai pris ma carte
sur le site du MoDem et c'est comme ça
que ça a commencé j'ai fait des études
de droit j'ai exercé la profession de
greffière pendant 7 ans à la cour
d'appel de Paris et à la Cour de
cassation et je suis maintenant à au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
à la DGCCRF en charge les questions
décides le Sénat ça m'évoque la façon de
participer à l'amélioration de la vie
des citoyens à la représentation des
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
ça m'évoque le jardin du Luxembourg
évidemment qui est situé dans le 6e
arrondissement c'est un endroit où
j'aime venir me promener ma candidature
aux élections sénatoriales elle est
faite dans une démarche collective c'est
une liste d'union avec le Mouvement
Démocrate Renaissance et horizon donc en
partie politique qui sont de la majorité
présidentielle il y a un sujet qui me
préoccupe c'est la fuite des Parisiens
et des familles parisiennes qui parient
pour aller s'installer ailleurs parce
qu'il ne trouve pas la tranquillité
nécessaire pour y maintenir leur famille
et donc ça c'est un sujet dont je
voudrais qu'on puisse se saisir de façon
plus globale la question de la
démocratie en France mais aussi dans les
grandes villes et notamment à Paris j'ai
pas toutes les solutions à proposer clé
en main aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas c'est un sujet dont
j'aimerais me saisir